[Musique]
les pompiers l'ont à 36,20 quelle
commune à peu près un jour ordinaire à
la brigade des sapeurs pompiers de
colmar
c'est dans cette salle que son traité
l'ensemble les appels au 18 aujourd'hui
les soldats du feu de travail en public
car le conseil départemental a souhaité
venir les voir une façon de remercier de
leur engagement lors de la crise du
coronavirus les sapeurs-pompiers ont
vraiment été en première ligne dans le
cadre de la crise sanitaire au plus
proche des malades qu'il devait
transférer dans les hôpitaux puisque ce
sont les sapeurs-pompiers qui allait
souvent au secours des malades à leur
domicile et qui faisait le transfert des
malades vers les hôpitaux dont qu'ils
étaient en première ligne
c'est pour moi l'occasion aujourd'hui de
leur dire toute ma reconnaissance et
toute la reconnaissance du conseil
d'administration du stif
nous sommes la cité de l'enfance à
colmar aujourd'hui c'est un jour un peu
particulier
marc keller et jérémy grimm du racing
club de strasbourg sont venus remettre
des masques aux jeunes du foyer
privé de match par la crise du coc vite
19 les joueurs de l'équipe ont souhaité
se montrer solidaire par des dons à
l'association femmes de foot
spontanément où ils ont eu envie de
donner de l'argent à femmes de foot de
faire une cagnotte avec le staff
technique donc on a décidé de tracer ce
don pour les masques à destination du
public et notamment des foyers d'enfance
donc on va redistribuer vers 1000 sur le
haut-rhin et le bas-rhin
voilà revenant des joueurs de foot je
pense que le message passe d'autant
mieux pour expliquer que c'est important
de porter son masque puis on apporte un
moment de bonheur aussi
en huit semaines l'association a dépensé
300 mille euros pour venir en aide à
ceux qui en avaient le plus besoin et
financer l'achat d'équipements de
protection pour les soignants les
structures médico-sociales les ehpad les
jeunes des foyers dans cette période un
petit peu trouble que nous traversons le
racing c'est aussi en général les gens
viennent vers nous aujourd'hui on va
vers eux depuis des semaines pour
essayer aussi de travailler sur le
terrain c'est un travail de fond qui a
été qui a été fait via femme de foot et
je suis très heureux et très fier de
voir le travail réalisé et c'est une
période un peu difficile pour tout le
monde c'est vrai que en tant que joueur
et tout le groupe et le club on essaye
de de donner ce qu'on peut donner voilà
on essaie de transmettre les valeurs
qu'on a actuelle donc là c'est vraiment
plaisir de pouvoir aider tout le monde
essaie de faire enfin essaie de faire du
mieux qu'on peut et doit de donner un
peu de sourire aux enfants ces voix là
ça me donne un peu plus de deux peuples
pour la suite à la maison de l'enfance
ces masques permettront d'apprendre aux
jeunes les mesures de protection utile
dès la fin du confinement
mais à la veille du déconfinement les
gestes barrière n'avait déjà plus de
secret pour eux on a eu beaucoup
d'inquiétudes au début par rapport aux
gestes barrières qu'on a appris aux
enfants leur a fait des cours d croit
que les éducateurs et des cours avec la
fermière est en fait c'est la force de
le faire ça rentre totalement dans la
vie quotidienne
donc on pense que l'apprentissage du
masque va prendre sûrement quelques
jours voire de quelques semaines mais on
fait avec
avec le temps je pense que les enfants
c'est eux qu'on plus de capacité à
s'adapter
donc je suis pas du tout inquiète par
rapport aux enfants de l'établissement
les jeunes de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
le confinement s'est fait dans les
foyers une situation difficile pour les
enfants comme pour les équipes nous
avons réussi à nous en sortir et bien
grâce à des équipes juste formidable des
équipes d'éducateurs qui sont dans ces
foyers qui ont accepté aussi de revoir
leurs horaires de travail leur manière
de travailler et c'est ce qui nous a
permis de passer dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et j'ai envie de
lire dans des conditions satisfaisantes
cette crise donc vraiment des équipes
formidables que je tiens aussi à
remercier le département a également
lancé l'opération un masque pour les
haut-rhinois l'idée que chaque habitant
se voit fournir un masque gratuit les
commandes ont été lancés courant avril
et distribution ont pu commencer début
mais nous nous sommes fait fort de
solliciter et de commander ces masques
auprès d'entreprises haut rhinoise en
l'occurrence le pôle textile alsace et
donc des masques vont être distribués
grâce à l'aide aussi des
intercommunalités dans chaque commune du
haut-rhin et les habitants pourront
venir
ce sont les communes qui vont les
organismes l'organiser pourront venir
récupérer leurs masques les haut rhinois
se retrouver en première ligne face au
corona virus le département a payé un
lourd tribut à l'épidémie
ainsi au conseil départemental on
souhaite également remercier les
habitants
je voudrais vous remercier mesdames
messieurs les haut rhinois et des haut
rhinoises pour ce que vous avez fait
durant ces deux mois parce que cette
chaîne de solidarité est bien propre
bien que les valeurs humanistes sont des
valeurs que vous portez ce n'est pas un
vain mot
ici en alsace bravo merci et bravo et
merci aussi d'avoir accepté la rigueur
du confinement
parce que c'est grâce à cette rigueur du
confinement qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
sur la carte verte des départements qui
sont très peu
des départements qui sont très peu
traversé aujourd'hui encore par le virus
bravo et merci aux haut rhinois